[Music]
olivia rodrigo's new single deja vu
just dropped it's about an ex who's
moved on with someone similar
and now fans think the 18 year old is
singing about her rumored ex
joshua bassett and his reported new
flame sabrina carpenter
that's pretty crazy
that we did that too she thinks it's
special
is anyone else having well deja vu
a big reason that i grew so much is
because i met joshua who is obviously
this
amazing musician songwriter and i think
before that i had never really met
anyone that was kind of interested in
the same things that i was interested in
that was like my age
and that was really inspiring and i
think he really pushes me to do better
the high school musical the musical the
series star released her new single on
thursday
her follow-up to the mega-popular
driver's license
[Music]
and like driver's license deja vu is
about someone
addressing a former lover who's moved on
with someone new
getting to write something that you know
will be like heard by people is
obviously
kind of a lot of pressure but i think
made me better as a songwriter totally
so is it about her former co-star in
rumored x and
sabrina here's why some eagle-eyed fans
say yes that green dress olivia's
rocking is
almost identical to this one sabrina war
to an event in january 2020
and don't blink or you just might miss
this fluffy pink number
that looks a whole lot like this look
sabrina shared on twitter in 2018
and at one point during the video olivia
sports
pigtail braids just like the 21 year old
actress
then there's this
[Music]
olivia sings about billy joel who josh
has covered
on the piano in the past
[Music]
the teen also sings in a pool emblazoned
with clouds and
sabrina she starred in the 2020 disney
flick
clouds is this what you wanted what i
want is to not have to lose my best
friend
and listen to this
[Music]
yeah their voices do kind of sound the
same
maybe we could have been friends if i
met you in another life
and they are both actresses of course
this all comes
after fans theorize that olivia's last
track driver's license was about the
reported love triangle
but when et sat down with josh last
month
he said he was laughing off all the
drama
i think the spot the songs speak for
themself that's really the truth like if
you listen
to him like that's the inspiration for
it you know um
but yeah it's funny just for me to see
people like
speculate or make theories about things
like i don't see a lot of it but what i
see
i'm like where are you getting this from
like
what it's so funny how people like
pieces together but you know i get it
we're all in quarantine everybody's got
nothing to do so everyone's trying to
make more meaning out of something than
there is as for the rumors that his
track
lie lie lie was a rebuttal to driver's
license
[Music]
[Applause]
well he had this to say plain and simple
it's just not
because of what played out i guess in
the media with you
and olivia did you guys at least get to
have a laugh on set
about everything of course yeah no
olivia's
amazing and we um you know we were
filming the season
throughout you know everything going on
and yeah all is well and we finished
strong
it was it was really great